hi and welcome to google developers live
my name is NASA Khan and I work for
Google Wallet we are going to talk about
orbits today orbits is one of our prima
partners who have done an integration
with Google Wallet api's and we're going
to go into more detail about what they
have done this is actually a two-part
segment so today we are going to focus
on the instant buy API s where as in the
following segment we can talk about
wallet objects API which relates to
offers so first of all let me welcome
Brian with joining us from orbitz Brian
you there yep hi hi how are you doing
today I'm doing good very excited about
this opportunity to share my experience
on this to buy API are you doing I'm
very well thank you and thanks for
joining us so the Android app that you
build and that you included instant buy
API is with it can you tell us a little
bit about what it does what the users
can do with it and and what what what
essentially it does it offer overall
sure our orbits web is the most
full-featured travel booking app
available on Android today not only can
you search and book hotels fleisch n
rental cars you can also access your
book tightener aries including the ones
you've booked on the website you can
also join our new orbits rewards loyalty
program directly from our app and start
earning rewards for your booking flights
hotels and use them instantly on hotels
and now with the Google Wallet instant
buy it's even easier to use our app to
take advantage of these great offers
great right so for instance I uh you
know for users who are not familiar with
instant buy i would recommend them to
look at our previous recording previous
videos but but in a nutshell it's
basically a payment api which which
which integrators can use in their
android app and the way it works is that
it makes it really simple for the users
to access your Google wallets from
within the native app and use it for
payments so we're going to see some
examples of this going forward but
essentially it's it streamlines the
process of payments to just about two or
three clicks versus a word cumbersome
entry process where users have to enter
their credit card information and things
of that kind so I believe you can show
us the app live Brian can you yes I can
all right so let's let's switch to the
app
i do wait and see how well you know just
see how what happens here so we can see
a screen now are you ready to demo sure
let's do a simple search for hotel in
chicago so click hotel to search it and
for the destination will type chicago
select chicago and select the dates and
click search
sure we'll just select a purse hotel
make sure we like it and select a room
so when you're into a booking screen as
you can see there's a lot of information
to populate if it's your first time
booking information like your name email
credit card info and billing address so
instead of filling everything in let's
see what happens when we click the buy
with Google button so just like that you
a list of credit card you have linked in
your google wallet and you can set it as
a default payment method as well what's
interesting to note here is that this
dialog and everything in it is actually
all card wallet API I didn't have to
make any of this dialogue or the content
side and in fact the orbitrap doesn't
even have access to this list of credit
cards all I had to do was create a
masked wallet request with a purchase
amount and send it using the google
wallet API which makes it really simple
for me as a developer so now that we
have this rules chu'lak card and click
continue and see what happens so now you
can see that the billing information is
updated with your Google Wallet email
address and your funding card
information our orbits have never
received the full credit card
information you have stored in Google
Wallet we just get and show the credit
card type and the last four digits of
the funding card for user reference and
this is basically what the masked wallet
object is see that the travel
information it's all pre-populated with
the information from the masked wallet
and just like that with just a single
click you're ready to check out and
since we have a promotion for using
Google Wallet instant buy right now
let's just make sure to get that
discount as well so now on you're ready
and when you clicked I agree and book
button this is when we actually make the
full wallet request via the google
wallet API and what this essentially
does is get a single use virtual proxy
card information which basically gets
passed on to our orbits back end to be
processed for payment perfect thank you
so much for the demo Brian so as ron was
telling that there are essentially two
steps in
just kind of recap that there is this
mass wallet which essentially happens
when the users click on the buy with
Google button for the first time this is
the first interaction of the users with
google wallet and what the get back is
this masked information which Brian was
showing on on the screen which has the
users address also the last four digits
of their backing card and then when the
user confirm it that is when a full
wallet request is made from within the
app which gets the proxy card which is a
one-time use card not exact not the card
that the users have in the abalan but a
proxy to that which can then be used
from within the app to actually make the
purchase or make the charge on it and so
this is a two-step very simple API we
were you first with a mass followed
request and then you do the full wallet
request and then the response you will
get what you need which is basically a
proxy card which you can then charge so
the benefit of this approach is that
once you have once you're set up for
let's say a credit card processing from
it in the app you're accepting users
entering their credit card you're pretty
much set up to use Google Wallet instant
buy because you can use the same rails
you get the proxy card almost as if the
user had typed in their credit card and
then use use it to process the charge as
if you are doing the credit card process
so it's the idea behind this approach
was to limit the integration effort
there the developers will have to do not
only in the front end but also in the
back end which is probably more
significant because then they don't have
to really integrate anything in the back
end so let me ask you Brian what I just
mentioned it did you experience the same
thing did you feel that it was an easier
integration or what are your general
thoughts about integration experience oh
as far as the integration was the happy
pets where we just had to implement a
very simple use case on the android app
side it was really straightforward right
idea at least the the hope that we had
viral we developed this api was to limit
the backend changes all together so is
that something that you also saw did you
have to make any changes in your
back-end right on payment processing
change usually is not really a simple
change but in this case the proxy card
was could be almost treated as like a
credit card so we had to do some
additional changes to support a Google
Wallet that it's actually google wallet
but as far as the actual process the
code is very just quite similar to a
regular credit card payment okay okay
and if i may ask who this Bryon
long did it actually take from start to
finish in terms of integrating instant
Buy in your app um well the very simple
happy pets just doing the art buy with
Google and getting the virtual Crossley
card it was actually the without any air
case and laying to maybe a day or two
that was really straightforward or and
in addition to that we had to do some
back-end changes from and we also had to
do some edge case handling and a lot of
testing so the whole process took about
a few weeks two to three weeks about
three to four weeks so depending on how
you look at the testing process but it
actually wasn't that bad yeah that's
pretty good actually I mean if you think
about the Lord which is a it's a pretty
big app and in terms of getting it live
in two to three weeks with a new API
that's pretty good so I in terms of
getting the app on on the on the Play
Store and getting people to use it are
you seeing are you seeing people now
using instant buy more and do you have
any feedback I think it's very early
days but you have any feedback from
users if they're finding a tea with
instant by versus filling out the forms
manually I'm sorry I missed our last
product ? in terms of what their
experience has been using instant by
versus filling out the forms manually oh
actually even before when we started the
instant by integration we are actually
having reviews that people wished that
they we had the google instant by
integration so it was great after we
integrated it we could reply to the user
that a we actually have this instant by
all and pre populate the forms a really
positive experience fantastic and
nothing thank you Brian thanks for your
time today and I don't forget to tune in
again for out the second segment of our
video in which we are going to talk
about the wallet objects API thank you
you